يصلحون ما صنعه ابائهم قبل عقود
سفنن خشبيه يفوق عمرها اعمارهم
يسميهم اهالي جنوبيه ايران بلهجهم المحليه
جلافان اي حرف في صناعه السفن الخشبيه
الحاج هاشم اكبرهم سنا واكثرهم خبره ورث
المهنه عن ابيه كان يصنع السفن فبات يعيد
الى الخدمه ما نال البحر منها
تتلمس في حديثه خشيه من اندثار هذه الصنعه
يتراوحوا عمر هذه السفن بين 50 و 100 عام
نعمل على اصلاحها ولم نعد نصنع سفنا جديدا
لان السفن المعدنيه على الرغم من ان عمرها
لا يتجاوز 25 عاما فقد احتلت مكان هذه
السفن
حرفه تعود الى عهد الدوله الافشاريه ارتبط
تاريخها بتاريخ الملاحه البحريه في هذه
المنطقه
استخدمت فيها الاخشاب المستورده من الهند
لكن لاسباب الاقتصاديه يكتفي الحرفيون
اليوم باخشاب محليه
ارتفاع تكاليف الصيانه وانتشار السفن
المعدنيه
وغياب الدعم الحكوميه دفعت ملاك السفن
الخشبيه الى تركها راسيه على الساحل
بانتظار ان تدفنها الرمال فحول المد
والجزر
تسمى
بمقبره السفن الخشبيه
ترفع
ولا شباك صيد ترمى في المياه بحثا عن
الرزق
فهذه السفن باتت شاهده على تاريخ الصناعه
مدرجه على قائمه اليونسكو للتراث غير
المادي ارسال
الخشبيه
وهي هويه تمثل هذه المدينه لكنها للاسف
مهدده بسبب الصناعات الحديثه لذانا مول من
الحكومه انقاذ هذا الكنز الثقافي
لطالما ابحرت هذه السفن على خطوط تصدير
البضائع ونقل الركاب الى العراق والدول
الخليجيه لكن قله منها تواصل هذه المهمه
اليوم تستعد هذه السفينه الخشبيه للابحار
نحو الضفه الاخرى من المياه لا تتحدى بذلك
امواجا قد تجرفها فحسب بل تواجه كل من
شانه اي يهدد بقاء هذه الصناعه عمر هواش
الجزيره مدينه بوشهر جنوب ايران